Welcome.
So this week we're going to be teaching a horse that has never free jumped a little
bit about the game of free jumping.
Some goals that you'll have for today is to make it fun for the horses and have them understand
and experience the exercise in a very attainable way so they don't feel like it's too hard
to accomplish or too complicated.
Some horses thrive in liberty work because they're very independent and other horses
feel that it's a little bit tricky to get started.
So firstly we want to warm the horses up by lunging.
This horse has been warmed up at liberty.
If your horse is not used to or you feel better starting them on a lunge line, that's okay
too.
And then as you can see I'm just walking really cautious and calmly over to the obstacles
and showing her how to step over them.
Our setup has extra jumps and rails as a chute.
You can also use pieces of caution tape or any sort of safe barricade that could come
down in case the horse misunderstands and tries to run out through the chute.
So in this case we've got little wings on either side as well to help guide the horses
into the chute so that they know where to go.
So step one is just to lead them over very small obstacles, just a pile of rails on the
ground.
You can do this with a horse that's done minimal jumping or more jumping as long as you stay
within the boundaries of what they already know how to do or what to do with their bodies.
So as you can see I'm leading her and I'm petting her when she does it correctly.
The next step after you've done this enough times that the horse really gets it is to
allow them to go on their own.
You see how I'm letting her sniff the way that she wants to go over the poles and I'm
just gently staying behind her in somewhat of a lunging position, rewarding her for the
first one.
And then just putting my arm kind of close to her bum as if I'm a little bit lunging
and quietly directing her to go around the poles.
If your horse is very keen or very excited sometimes they'll run off away from you and
that's okay too.
Just be careful that you're not in harm's way if your horse is not very aware of your
surroundings.
This one is very aware of the surroundings.
So you see how she's just walking away, she's taking some liberties, so I'm just engaging
in that lunging kind of posture again with minimal pressure and now I've even been able
to advance to being outside the chute and just talking to her and indicating.
Important thing is to not rush the horses if they still feel the need to walk over the
obstacles, allow them to do that.
So when I squat down like that, that's an indicator of a little break and the horse
is allowed to relax or stay quiet for a moment.
I want to get up again, I'm just going to direct her gently with my body position to
go the way that I intend her to go.
This is very important when the horse walks towards you like that they're asking for help.
So you see me immediately, I'm not pushing from behind anymore, I go straight to her
and I get into a leading position because she clearly got confused of which direction
she should go.
Good, and you see her looking back at me for clarity and then she comes back.
Again this is a very very unique and authentic video, this horse has never free jumped before,
it's never been through a chute.
So this is a very good example of some of your horses if you've never free jumped them
before.
So you see there when she went to go into the chute, I didn't persist or intend for
her to do that so she turned around to come back towards me and that's an acceptable
reaction.
So at no point do you want to be chasing the horses through the chute, they never jump
well like that and they don't have a good understanding.
You want to teach them the exercise and have them go through as they know how and are able.
Much better.
So in this case, aww she's going to the camera man, that's extra cute.
So after some repetitions on the one direction then you can switch sides and even increase
to standing on the end of the chute and letting the horse fully propel its own mind through
the chute, solving all the problems as they go along.
In this particular video you can't hear me saying the praises but I'm indicating with
my voice when to trot and I'm telling her good girl and that is really helping her mood
and her excitement on the subject.
When she's waiting for me like that, that's a very good sign she's understanding the game
and she's starting to know what's expected of her.
So secondly you're going to want to trot in and give them a little momentum, you see me
clapping my hands to encourage her to keep trotting and there she's accepting the reward
and going back to the end of the chute.
Coming and standing next to people is a very good sign for the horses, it's an indication
that they're ready for a reward and you've done a good job with your reward training.
So no matter how the horse goes over the obstacles you're still going to praise them for going
through the chute correctly.
Today we're probably not going to get very far with the jump height and that's a very
good idea.
You want to teach the horse the skills and the set up just the way we teach ourselves.
We want to teach technique first and then go further.
After you get some confidence with cross rails then you can set up a small vertical and just
make sure that the distances are agreeable.
This is a very open two so you can trot in and get a nice three between the two fences
and it's not too awkward for the horses.
Some really important things to remember is to take your time to lower your expectations
for the first few times and just let the horse experience going through the chute correctly.
If you have to keep the rails on the ground for the entire first time, keep leading them,
those things, stay at that exact same spot for a while before moving on to the next stage.
As the horse gets confident they'll start to go on their own or direct themselves to
the chute.
There you see the horse getting very excited and happy.
This is a good sign.
That means that they're getting more comfortable and more excited and happy about the exercise.
Be sure to be giving the horse breaks depending on their fitness and lots of pats and praise
for simply just engaging with you and having an attempt to listen and learn from you.
Lastly when the horse can be led in and then closely followed then you can send them into
the chute on their own like a large lunge circle.
You can start to almost just lunge them straight into the chute and if they get confused on
direction just gently go back to the lunge position.
You see I just changed my mind and we're going to lunge to the right there.
As your horse gets better at it then you can be more strict and help them with their direction
but understand that for the most part they're just confused on which direction to go and
that's okay.
Just redirect them and you'll be surprised at how much effort they give you.
For the first day that's a perfectly acceptable goal doing two verticals in the chute and
being able to do it all on her own.
This is a great conclusion to her lesson today and she's very happy and rambunctious about
it.
It's a very good sign that she is engaged to work and thinks this is quite a fun game.
As we wind down here you see me offering myself as a steady place to get a pet and she's still
having a little bit of fun and when she's done having her fun she's going to come back
to me and get her pet and that's okay too.